construct an equilateral triangle
inscribed inside the circle
so let me construct a circle that has
the exact same dimensions as our
original circle
looks pretty good and now let me move
this center so it sits on our original
circle so they now sit on each other or
their centers now sit on each other so i
can make it
that looks pretty
pretty good
and now let's think about something
if i were to draw
this segment right over here this of
course it has the length of the radius
now let's do another one and that's
either of their radii because they have
the same length
now let's just center this at our new
circle
let's center it at our new circle and
take it out here now this is equal to
the radius of the new circle which is
the radius same as the radius of the old
circle is going to be the same as this
length here so these two segments have
the same length
now
if i were to construct if i were to
connect that point to that point this is
a radius of our original circle
and so it's going to have the same
length as these two so this right over
here i have constructed an equilateral
and equilateral triangle now why is
why is this at all useful
well we know that the angles in an
equilateral triangle are 60 degrees so
we know that this angle right over here
is 60 degrees now why is why is that why
is this being 60 degrees interesting
well imagine if we constructed another
triangle out here
just symmetrically but kind of flipped
down just like this
well the same argument this angle right
over here between these two edges this
is also going to be 60 degrees so this
entire
interior angle
if we add those two up are going to be
120 degrees
now why is that interesting well if this
interior angle is 120 degrees then that
means that this arc right over here is
120 degrees or it's a third of the way
around the triangle this right over here
is a third of the way around the
triangle
since that's a third of the way around
the triangle if i were to connect if i
were to connect these two dots
if i were to connect these two dots
that is going to be
this this right over here is going to be
a side
of our equilateral triangle it's this
right over here it's it's it's secant to
an arc that is one third of the entire
circle and now i can keep doing this
let's move
let's move i'll reuse these let's move
our circle around and so now i'm going
to move my circle along the
circumference around along the circle
and what i want again i just want to
intersect these two points and so now
let's see i can take one of these
take it there
take it there same exact argument
this
this right this angle that i haven't
fully drawn or this arc you could say is
120 degrees so this this is going to be
one side of our equilateral triangle
it's secant to an arc of 120 degrees so
let's move this around again actually we
don't even have to move this around
anymore we could just
we could just connect those last two
dots so we could just connect
this one actually i just want to let's
connect that one to that one
and just like that
and we're done we have constructed our
equilateral triangle